i like making noises  in what way  [Music]  [Music]  a promising first concert a wonderful  fact  [Applause]  [Music]  but it's time to move on  and continue our investigacion into an  array of intercountry disciplines  flatulence  yes  and deep breath  am i going to die  name me a living thing that isn't  she says what she likes what she doesn't  like i could replace them and nothing  would change i stop and smile we're all  hovering something that will be purging  [Music]  how backstage of you is in this  everything  and with that we need to go further into  oblivion  [Music]  wait till i write my memoirs  you write those memoirs  i will  [Music]  cooking and performing is a hazard  happens all the time this kind of thing  [Music]  you